[Musique]
ce jeudi 20 juillet le département a
décentralisé son marché pays sur le
front de mer de saint-pierre pour la
deuxième fois afin que tous les
réunionnais puissent profiter de ces
moments de proximité avec les
producteurs ils étaient 25 à avoir
répondu présent avec tous la même envie
revenir plus souvent
oui c'est une très bonne chose parce que
la profession est un peu en souffrance à
l'heure actuelle donc ans lorsqu'on
déplace comme ça bon on fait des
vos clients donc ça nous emmène à avoir
quelque chose de puisque c'est déjà une
bonne chose du conseil départemental
parce qu'il permet
aux producteurs de faire connaître de
nouveaux produits aux clients en
matériaux que nous sommes dans notre bon
droit du côté de saint paul nous dit
notre santé et pour moi c'est ma
première fois la même je trouve que je
connais pas tellement c'est l'émir
découvert ce qui apporte amassé que vous
voit de nouvelles têtes et il fait
plaisir pour les gens les auront de voir
des nouveaux produits des produits frais
par le marché pays ben pour moi il faut
pas y être là et continue à être
satisfait pour parrot l'emplacement et
les cafés elle s'approche du côté des
passants d'enthousiasmé tes semblables
l'opportunité d'avoir un contact direct
avec les producteurs mais aussi de
consommer des produits de qualité et
c'est un faux mis à boire et franchement
mais trouve bien puisque leur petite
famille noter les produits data vault
produits bio sûrement parce que
maintenant c'est c'est bio super mais on
va le marché
mais bien de référé différemment
retrouvez le marché pays habituel tous
les deuxièmes samedis du mois à l'espace
régler à saint denis
[Musique]